[Music]
is Brian Cranston set to join his time
he's ready to go oh Brian Cranston great
actor and uh he's done a wonderful thing
he called us last week and he said look
I got tickets and you can go to the
Super Bowl uh you're going to be we'll
fly you in give you a hotel you get to
meet Brian Cranston as well and I said
okay and he said but every bit of the
money raised goes to Big Brothers Big
Sisters of America every single penny
and all you have to do is go to Brian
Cranston big game.com you have to uh
donate five dollars that's the minimum
donation but two seats to the big game
airfare hotel ground transportation and
you can meet Brian as well and thanks to
the generosity of NFL and pop corners
and Brian joining us how much money have
we raised so far bro
oh Danny it's up to it's up to about 125
000 awesome yeah so it's really good but
but let me let me take a moment here
Grandpa yeah what a great moment I I
just just listening to your story gave
me an a high ankle sprain
I'm telling it it I I was with you I I
have I have Grandpa Envy of you right
now can you cry on cue
I'm crying right now my friend okay
um yeah yes I can now what do you use
what is your imagery that you use to cry
on cue
you know most of
them because you have those personal
memories as an actor as part of the the
tool chest is that when you need those
emotions you kind of save them because
if you dip in too much too often
um then it starts to lose its impact so
you kind of keep that private and every
actor has a place that they can go that
they remember that feeling of either
overwhelming Joy or overwhelming sadness
yeah and and you pull that out when you
need it but you did this in Breaking Bad
you talked about this that uh what was
it Jesse's girlfriend dies right in
front of you and I think you said that
you thought of your daughter in that
moment but I don't know how often you
can draw you know if down the road if
you have an emotional moment that if you
want to draw from me becoming a
grandfather for the first time I mean
I'd be honored if you say you know when
somebody says oh what were you thinking
Dan Patrick becoming a grandfather
I tell you that there's there's that's
not far away from what I could use okay
because uh you know Aaron Paul has a a
beautiful five-year-old daughter and a
and a young boy who's gonna turn one I'm
uh his name is Ryden I'm his his
Godfather and I just love these kids I
love them and I I I tell them all the
time I said anytime you want to hand
them to me I'm good you know give them
to me and I just there's something so
magical about it and so I'm getting my
grandfather fix out of that I I really
going through that you know like you'll
hear some men and women going through oh
I've got to have I'm feeling this the
urge to have kids and now I have that
urge so I can picture you on that patio
on that balcony just kind of pacing and
feeling the emotion of what what has
just happened for you in your life I'm
really happy for you well I was is a
little aware of the people walking by on
a busy street and looking up and seeing
me crying and wondering like why is Dan
Patrick on a balcony crying but that was
what was happening uh yesterday but you
know what I I have an assumption that
the assumption that they recognized you
did wow wow that's a shot that's that's
a shot say that to my face Cranston
say it to my face uh when are you coming
to town by the way
I'm coming Thursday how's the weather
uh it's a little uh cool in the morning
but it's nice in the afternoon yeah
it's not not anywhere I mean you're
you're out from the the Northeast it's
not cool like that no no no it was minus
one when we left on Saturday you know
people are like it's 40 degrees I go
yeah that's a high you know in
Connecticut well we're at the Ballpark
here and it's a beautiful setting so uh
even though it's the Giants and I know
you're a Dodger fan so but uh they're
great great people are you stopping by
this set on Friday
I I am going to see if I can yeah we
have a pretty packed schedule but we
have to make the announcement when are
we making the announcement on who won
these two two tickets
that's tomorrow morning on your show
okay all right I'll be on Zoom
yeah can they I just wanted to call in
to remind everybody to to go to
bryancranston big game.com five dollar
donation minimum get on there you could
win two tickets to the game the airfare
the hotel ground track of the whole
thing and um and and then I'll see you
there
uh thanks again for your generosity and
your friendship and uh once again you
have that chance to enter and it's a
minimum donation five dollars and Ryan
was uh very upfront about this saying
that the Big Sisters Big Brothers Big
Sisters of America will get every penny
raised and uh right now over 125 000 I
look forward to talking to you tomorrow
and we'll reveal the winner here Brian
thanks Grandpa I'll see you tomorrow
it's Brian Cranston